is there a place
Bob Marley's grandson Joe Mercer Marley
has died he was 31 years old
a rep for the musician confirmed the sad
news to Rolling Stone on Tuesday but a
cause of death has yet to be revealed
there is one question
Joe is the grandson of Bob Marley and
the son of Stephen Marley the family's
impact on reggae music and the industry
as a whole has spanned decades lovely
lovely Vibes who come to represent music
and music that is a good part of a
gathering since news broke of Joe's
death the prime minister of Jamaica
Andrew holness shared his condolences on
Twitter writing quote my heartfelt
sympathies to Joseph's friends and
Associates and to the reggae music
fraternity and fans everywhere adding
that his death is a huge loss
[Music]
in a follow-up tweet the politician
wrote quote may he find Eternal peace as
we mourn his loss during this season of
Goodwill when we celebrate with family
and friends our love for each other
[Music]
wants to be following in the family
business Joe was a reggae and dance hall
musician in 2014 he released his debut
EP comfortable and in 2020 he dropped
Everlasting remixes the jamaican-born
artist's last body of work was eternal a
seven-track EP
[Music]
None Shall escape the Judgment there's
no will